hey what's up guys my name is Jenna and
welcome to episode 23 of Navajo chapter
I mean last time we left off on quite a
big cliffhanger we had this little 1024
problem here why is the length 1024 I
bet you guys were at the edge of your
seats message that length was indeed
1024 and not seven like we wanted it to
be why is that the case well welcome to
network share programming and today
we're gonna find out why that's the case
so the reason that's the case as you
might have probably guessed by now is we
create a new byte of data that we
receive or send and it is a byte that is
1024 okay we receive 1024 bytes which is
one kilobyte of data now now we might
not necessarily want to process all of
that data okay if we send something
simple which is actually what we've been
doing right all we've been sending is a
simple full slash seafloor slash
followed by a four-digit number which is
the client's ID that's all we're sending
here all right so then why on earth
right why on earth are we getting this
kind of 1024 like why why is it sending
the entire thing we only want to send a
portion of it and the reason it's doing
that is because whenever telling it to
end
ok so what we need to do is essentially
tell the thing to end but we can't okay
we can't just simply be like all right
byte slice yourself in half we don't
need half you can't be like that
because then byte would get quite
offended and might go into the corner
and cry so what we need to do instead is
figure out a method I'll figure out a
way essentially I don't want to use a
word method because then you think I'm
referring to like a function or
something an actual physical method
method like get name for example wind if
we need to figure out a way that
actually lets us kind of tell ourselves
when the end of the message should be so
kind of like on a radio you would you
would be like hey man what's going on
over right over you use the word over to
kind of be like this is the end of the
message or um well yeah okay I guess in
our telegrams you use the word stop but
that that's just a space so it's a bit
different there but yeah so you use the
word
over that's kind of what we need to do
here that's probably the best analogy
I've come up with thus far okay that's
what we need to do we actually need to
go ahead and
say this is the end of the message we
need a kind of like a termination
character so the thing that we're going
to do for that okay and go over here
into our server send message which is um
send send method here what we will do
right is at the end of here when we send
something with a byte of data every time
we send what we want to do is instead of
just send ID and that and then that's it
we don't want to do that what we
actually want to do is cut out one
little process here I'm just thinking
about I want to do this okay so what
we're gonna do is actually make a new
send method in the server so private
words send this will be a simple string
called message alright and what this
will do is well actually it just won't
be simply a string it'll be a string
message it will also be a I'll be an
owner dress address and it'll be an
import okay so what this will do is this
will call the sender method it will
convert that message well actually first
thing it'll do is it'll actually add
something to the message which we're
going to figure out in a minute but also
will convert the message so get bytes
will convert the message into a into a
byte array we will of course forward it
to the address and the port now what
will we add to the message very very
simple we will simply add something
called well knit in in our case because
we want to be all custom and stuff full
/ 1/4 / all right /a /li sat for the end
you could use something like an old 0
character which is that Oh technically
it's that but we can't really do that
and what we can but we don't want to so
II okay that's what we're gonna use so
an e in Cherno chat means well the end
kind of okay so now that we've done that
we of course need to change our way of
doing things here so in this process
instead of just sending our data get by
it straight away we can simply just send
ID and that will of course use this math
method which will add the e little thing
on the end and do this stuff great so
what does that allow us do in actual
client
speak so if message starts with C right
then let's put out the length first of
all well actually when in nature we know
that's gonna be 1024 what we'll do is
instead of simply splitting the message
at C which means that what happens is
let's just let's just visualize this
quickly right so what our string should
look like right now is going to be very
simple it's gonna be that so for such C
faults slash followed by a random number
like 8 1 2 5 for example and then it's
going to be followed by a false lash a
false lash and then is gonna be followed
by well the rest is gonna be spaces ok
that's how it's gonna work so what we
need to do is we can split the message
by not just C because what we really
want is that is the the kind of the the
data in between the two false lashes or
well not really the data in between the
two kind of characters that we've got
here C and E which are of course are
surrounded by false letters to make sure
that they're actually not just normal
characters so what we need to do is not
just split it by C but also because what
if we just split it by say what it's
gonna do is it's gonna cut out C all
right it's gonna basically put
everything before C as 0 in this array
everything after C which is basically
the whole of this will be now known as 1
right now what we want to do is just cut
it to this so what we can do is also use
the e as a delimiter ok and what that
will let us do is of course make sure
that this will be indexed like
everything here will be indexed 0 in the
array this will be indexed 1 in the
array and everything passed will be
indexed 2 in the array so will you keep
it at 1 but what we will add is it is a
pipe little thing here it's like the or
operator and then we'll add a and unless
us basically this all operator lets us
kind of use different delimiters all at
once ok
so now if we try and run this little
glorious method and we have to update
everything else in a minute but this
should probably work if we try and run
this and we'll go Y on localhost up well
let's first of all stop the server that
could probably be useful at times we'll
go ahead and start the server we're
going to go ahead into client into login
sorry
we'll open that and we will yon
localhost 8 1 9 to log in and you can
see the week at a CSS we came up to the
server with ID 1 3 5 6 which is exactly
1 3 5 6 what our server told us we would
be connecting up ok and that's it so
everything works ok so that's the end
character I'm gonna call this episode
and the character cuz it sounds cool but
also because that's effectively what it
is so um I hope you guys did enjoy this
episode so it was a bit short but I'll
see you guys next time with another one
if you did enjoy this if you enjoyed
this like it's a cliff hang on but we
didn't enjoy that but it won it was
pretty fun I have to admit for myself if
you did enjoy this episode though please
hit a like button and I'll see you guys
in another video probably the next
episode of network jabber going goodbye
you